They've long since cemented themselves as
beloved pop culture icons, but what do we
really know about Jay and his longtime companion
Silent Bob?
We've compiled an exhaustive timeline of the
lives, loves, trials and good fortunes of
this foulmouthed dynamic duo.
If you're wondering where the story of Jay
and Silent Bob begins, it might be best to
start with Genesis — the book of the Bible,
not the band.
Yes, the biblical story of creation is canon
within Kevin Smith's universe, and it's more
relevant than you might think.
As outlined in Dogma, the stories of the Bible
hold literal sway in the View Askewniverse,
with Biblical figures — including God herself
— showing up to influence the events of
the world — and also to kill people.
In the beginning, God created all that is,
developed an unknowable plan for existence,
and looked suspiciously like Alanis Morissette.
While a lot of the events depicted in the
holy texts are presented as subjective and
even misleading, turns out the story was,
in broad strokes, pretty accurate.
"Is that a f---in' Bible?"
"Hey, the Holy f---in' Bible, son."
Why is this important?
Well, aside from answering man's most fundamental
questions about nature, being, and the nature
of existence, it sets the stage nicely for
two stoners to meet at a convenience store
in New Jersey in the 1970s.
The place?
The unincorporated community of Leonardo,
New Jersey, just outside the Quick Stop.
The time?
The 1970s.
What is about to occur is nothing short of
destiny.
"What the hell?
Excuse me, who's watching these babies?"
"The fat one's watching the little one."
Just like that, Jay and Silent Bob were united,
hetero life-mates from the cradle to the grave.
Also, did you know Kevin Smith's daughter
is playing baby Silent Bob?
It's her screen debut.
It's adorable.
That's right, savages, the second movie in
the Askewniverse takes place before the first.
Here's how you can tell:
Most of Mallrats revolves around a dating
game show, run by Michael Rooker's character
machiavellian Jared Svenning.
After tragedy strikes the original contestant,
Svenning's daughter Brandi is forced to replace
her on the game show at the last minute.
“My dad’s asked me to help him with his
new show.”
“What, like his assistant?”
“As a contestant.”
“You mean that dating game ripoff thing?!
That IS what you’re talking about here,
right?”
The original contestant is named Julie Dwyer.
Wanting to look skinny for the cameras, she
goes on an ill-advised exercise binge at the
YMCA pool, unexpectedly dying of a brain embolism
in the process.
This disaster triggers the plot of Mallrats,
with the boyfriend of Svenning's daughter,
Quint, and his friend Brodie ending up in
a cartoonish farce with Jay and Silent Bob
at the local mall, where the game show is
being shot.
In the end, Quint wins over his girlfriend,
Ben Affleck goes to jail, and we're promised
that Jay and SIlent Bob will get an orangutan
someday.
And they will.
Just not yet.
This brings us to Clerks, Kevin Smith's first
movie.
In this film, Quick Stop employee Dante and
his pal Randal attend Julie Dwyer's wake,
placing the movie directly after the events
of Mallrats.
It's like the Indiana Jones movies, but with
more pot.
Clerks introduced the world to Jay and Silent
Bob, scumbag supporting characters who serve
as counterpoints to the main characters' dour
minimum wage existence.
They also served as founts of wisdom and a
stoner Greek chorus.
Jay and Silent Bob spend the majority of Clerks
doing what they do best.
They hang out in front of the Quick Stop,
slinging drugs while Jay makes noise and Bob
doesn't.
At first glance, the romantic comedy Chasing
Amy doesn't feel like a Jay and Silent Bob
story at all with no snoochies nor boochies
to be found.
This is a movie about love.
Smith mainstays Ben Affleck and Jason Lee
play creative partners on a comic book series
titled Bluntman and Chronic, which details
the lives and adventures of two vigilante
stoners, one lithe, loud, and obnoxious, the
other portly and less verbal.
They are, of course, based on Jay and Silent
Bob, who Ben Affleck's character, Holden,
goes to meet at a diner to pay them their
royalties for their likeness rights.
There, Silent Bob delivers his biggest speech
to date, giving the movie its title.
"You're Chasing Amy."
He also reveals an unprecedented number of
details about his own personal life, including
a lifelong desire to be a dancer.
But there's more backstory to this scene than
the movies even fill you in on.
Before they go to meet Holden, Jay and Silent
Bob crash in the living room of Mallrats character
Trish Jones, sister to Chasing Amy's Allyssa
Jones, in a story that connects the stoners'
arc from Mallrats to the movies that follow.
A four-issue comic book miniseries, Chasing
Dogma, bridges the gap between Chasing Amy
and Dogma, finally answering the question
"Hey, what do you think Jay and Bob were doing
around 1998?"
"Smoking weed, drinking beers, doing coke,
drinking beers, drinking beers beers beers,
rolling fatties, smoking blunts, who smokes
the blunts?
We smoke the blunts"
Here's the basic synopsis: after Jay gets
the two of them thrown out of Trish's house,
the duo heads to the mall's department store
to watch John Hughes movies on VHS.
They get in a fight, then get kicked out of
the RST Video parking lot.
They they head to Shermer, Illinois to try
and sell weed to the Brat Pack characters,
then get verbally assaulted by Mister Rogers,
eventually landing work on the set of an adult
film directed by Neil Patrick Harris called
Doogie Nights, and that's all in the first
two issues.
In a weird twist, issue three explores their
adoption of an escaped orangutan and subsequent
scrapes with a federal wildlife marshal, which
will sound familiar to some.
Yes, that particular storyline from Jay and
Silent Bob Strike Back apparently happened
twice.
At the end of the run, Jay and Bob discover
that there is no Shermer, Illinois, and decide
to bury their disappointment by heading to
a family planning clinic to meet women.
They're nothing if not consistent.
Theologically speaking, everything sort of
comes to a head for New Jersey's favorite
unlicensed herbal peddlers in 1999, when,
while cruising at the clinic, they meet Bethany
Sloane, the last descendant of a genetic line
shared by Jesus Christ.
This is the movie in which Jay and Bob are
revealed to be prophets sent by God, which
still isn't "ironic," though it is amusing.
Jay and Bob escort Bethany on an interstate
journey of self-discovery and heavy religious
introspection.
Along the way, they befriend Rufus, the secret
13th apostle, and Serendipity, a muse responsible
for most of history's most financially successful
box office performances.
Silent Bob proves to be a remarkably effective
demon slayer, defeating two actual demons
over the course of the adventure.
Jay has less success, and his attempts to
kill a fallen angel with an Uzi mostly make
things worse.
Still, through offhand remarks, he takes a
potential end of the world scenario off the
burner and helps to save God from a comatose
state incurred during one of the Almighty's
trips down to Earth to play skeeball.
Bethany immaculately conceives a holy child,
and according to Kevin Smith, that's all we'll
be hearing on the matter.
After four movies and various side projects
in the supporting cast, 2001's Jay and Silent
Bob Strike Back put the pair center stage.
The movie sees the duo learning two important
things: one, Hollywood is adapting Bluntman
and Chronic into a big budget blockbuster,
and they deserve a cut of the royalties.
Two, the internet exists, and people are mean
there.
"We gotta put a stop to these f---in hateful
sons of b----es before they ruin our good
names."
The two head off to Hollywood to try and shut
down the movie, or at least get paid their
share for their likenesses.
Along the way, they befriend a quartet of
female jewel thieves masquerading as animal
rights activists, and are conned into stealing
an orangutan from an animal testing facility
as part of an elaborate coverup.
Bob and the ape become dear friends.
Jay falls in love with one of the criminals,
and Will Ferrell appears as a Will Ferrell
character.
The jewel thieves are arrested after Justice,
the member of the group who garnered Jay's
affections, turns them in to save Jay and
Bob from going down for a crime they didn't
commit.
She asks Jay to wait for her while she's incarcerated.
Jay and Bob confront Banky Edwards, the co-creator
of Bluntman and Chronic played by Jason Lee,
and walk away with a cherry cut of the proceeds
from the forthcoming feature film, leaving
them financially solvent for the foreseeable
future.
Shockingly, in the years between Jay and Silent
Bob Strike Back and Clerks II, the beloved
Quick Stop burned to the ground.
Our boys aren't to blame, though — they
were in rehab at the time.
As chronicled by Jay during his first day
back at work, they bought a car, but were
pulled over for suspicion of mischief, also
known as
"Driving around with a deployed airbag.”
The police found marijuana in their vehicle
and the dynamic duo was sentenced to six months
of rehab.
Back on the outside, they continued dealing
drugs, but stopped using.
They also seemingly picked their business
venue based solely on where Dante and Randal
were working at the time, setting up shop
in front of a Mooby's fast food restaurant.
They keep to themselves in the background
for the most part.
Silent Bob achieves his dance dreams in a
sequence of heightened reality, and the two
are arrested again during a madcap comedy
of errors surrounding a donkey show put on
inside the restaurant.
After everyone gets taken to jail, the two
offer to finance Dante and Randal's reclamation
of the rebuilt Quick Stop in exchange for
a permanent residency in front of the store.
As the credits roll, a line of text reads
"Jay and Silent Bob might return someday.
Until then, they're taking it easy."
Fans speculated as to whether or not they'd
ever see their heroes again.
13 years passed.
And then...
After a decade-long career detour with the
studio comedies Zack and Miri Make a Porno
and Cop Out, as well as a dark horror phase
centered on the great white north of Canada,
Kevin Smith decided he was ready to go back
to the View Askewniverse.
The return is officially kicking off in October
2019.
Remember the plot of Jay and Silent Bob Strike
Back?
Kevin Smith has described the sequel as being
basically the same movie, even comparing it
to director Gus Van Sant's shot-for-shot Psycho
remake.
"Where we taking it from, Gus?"
"I'm busy."
"You're a true artist, Gus."
The movie will follow Jay and Silent Bob as
they try to stop a big-budget Hollywood remake
of the movie they tried to put a stop to in
Strike Back.
A ton of Smith regulars make appearances,
including Ben Affleck, Jason Lee, and Shannon
Elizabeth, reprising her role as Justice,
who introduces Jay to their love child Millie,
played by Kevin Smith's kid, Harley Quinn
Smith.
She's less adorable this time around, though.
This time, she means business.
"Either you take us both to Hollywood or I
stab you to death on my front f---ing lawn."
Well, like father, like kid.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.